ciao amore auguri buon san valentino
[Musica]
hai visto che indosso la tua sottoveste
proferita non vedo l'ora di vederti
amore mio mi manchi ti amo
un giorno sarà il mio che bello che sei
e chi l'ha detto che devono festeggiare
soltanto le coppie se la festa degli
innamorati
io vi amo da morire e questa serata è la
mia serata un bel po di relax
sorseggiando il mio cocktail preferito
ricordando la mia serie tv preferita
in amore non funziona mica così no non è
che perché lui che ha lasciato ha detto
di passare stamani di una casa a
piangere dei primati a guardare il film
strappalacrime no amore noi a favore di
riusciamo e ti voglio carica come una
molla
noi ci devastiamo abbiamo prima cena e
andiamo a ballare alla facciata del tuo
ex non posso desiderare un san valentino
migliore divano coperta è il libro di
marina che mi appena arrivato come non
sapete che uscito il libro di marina ma
certo si chiama cuore corazza lo trovate
già in tutte le librerie e su tutte le
piattaforme digitali
io vi consiglio di farvi questo bel
regalo per san valentino non ne
rimarrete delusi adesso scusate devo
leggere ciao
sfiga non mi sono preso l'influenza per
tutto l'anno e mi ammalo proprio san
valentino l'unico anno in cui potevo
festeggiarlo amo o pochissimo tempo ed è
in doccia
allora mi ha appena detto chiariti
libero per il 14 però non mi ha detto
che il 14 sera quindi secondo me è una
cosa che dura tutta la giornata quindi
potrebbe essere ore perno o una gita
fuori porta oppure shopping sfrenato dal
mattino alla sera adoro la sauna del suo
telefono l'ha dimenticato qui cosa
faccio guardo il tuo volo è stato
confermato per lo stato un villaggio non
so che non si fa ma devo vedere devo
vedere vari milano amo ha invitato sua
mamma qui a casa nostra voce è finito ma
io mi chiedo ma cosa avete da avesse già
re che poi lo sanno tutti e soprattutto
una festa consumistica e nata per
vendere di più per veneri cioccolatini
per vendere le rose l'ex schifezze che
io odio san valentino anzi io odio
l'amore io odio le coppie che si
sbaciucchiano il m
io odio tutti quelli che sono innamorati
e felici
ecco cosa odio io che se facendo muore
sto studiando ti ho detto di no non ha
senso che io venga a cena per due ore se
con l'ansia che giorno dopo l'esame
no no no è l'ultimo appello devo per
forza per forza passarlo dai festeggiamo
dopo la sessione amore ora fanchini di
studiare
c'è ma che nevegal e san valentino sai
14 febbraio è il mio compleanno it's my
birthday bce che ha portato un pacco
happy birthday
non vedo l'ora di negare angelo tutte
felici come loro fidanzati tutta la mia
amica sono piazzati io sono l'unica fino
a maggio più estranei uguale meno male
che ci sono 100 ml cavo che ti devo dire
e ovvio che sono triste san valentino
tutti sanno che propri fidanzati e un
posto perché lui abita lontano però è
così nei fatti tutti che pensano un
regalo a me basterebbe stare con lui
guarda
io odio san valentino io dormire ma io
sono senza parole guarda ma ci ho
provato ho provato niente
cioè se stesse non voglio andar mi
licenziano per forza devo lavorare pure
a san valentino
mi avevano detto a capodanno che se
avessi lavorato a capodanno mi lasciava
una casa san marino invece no
e invece no perché manca il personale
perché sono tutti a casa con influenze
chi se la prende quel posto
niente lavorerò anche se vuole fino a
ora dice no non me l'aspettavo è tutto
così romantico grazie e non è ancora
finita
no dai amore vado detto che ti regali
non ho resistito
non è vero sono pazzo di te
marina marina sì sì sì siamo arrivati
alla fine del libro no scusate siamo
arrivati alla fine del video è come al
solito vi ricordo se non avete ancora
fatto di iscrivervi al canale e di
seguirmi su tutti gli altri social
facebook
instagram e tic toc e inoltre fatemi
sapere con un commento qui sotto
a quale di queste tipologie appartenete
io ovviamente appartengo alla lettrice
sarò di parte ma io vi mando un bacione
norme e vi auguro buon san valentino e
vi ricordo che tra pochissimo
inizieranno i firma copie di cuore
corazza quindi avremo modo di vederci
incontrarci in giro per l'italia
ciao
[Musica]